sports betting thoughts no this past
week i went to the dolphins bills game
to film
on do you gamble or bet on football
and or do you play fantasy football yeah
and a lot of people do obviously they're
we're going to a football crowd a lot of
people do yeah
truth be told you know i'm not sure uh
this is legal or not legal back in
college i used to run book
meaning i should take bets to make money
right it wasn't a big deal yeah
my opinion this might get people
a little salty yeah colossal waste of
time
colossal waste of time anything like
that on sports all of it all of it all
of it
anything you make you're going to give
back
yeah you're going to
you're going to lose and you're going to
try to chase the jag and try to win
they're going to lose more are you going
to get too close to the sun we talked
about a segment on this
is investing in crypto
investing or gambling okay
the difference between
uh the two strategy
i could argue strategy in sports better
very little bit because you have no
control over this
your team might get hurt i'm sorry your
player might get hurt your team's
just he asked my thoughts on sports
betting sure you want to take a couple
bucks and have fun make sure this ain't
rent money okay they say they shouldn't
be paying your rent yeah okay that's it
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken